[Music]
you thought we're going to talk about
with the images of course this London
lineup and these are some of images on
our website and also I would like to go
beyond images so actually I think it
really matches well with the previous
talk tour in recommendations how to use
the basically network speed or shallow
or deep each other's own and we're going
to talk about and see how we can make
use of this line tricks for other
recommendations as well I just say like
much okay I think if I was you so you
can start no no okay again nope
so oh my Cooper is going to sleep so a
little bit about outline I have a screen
that so when to use deep learning so
that's not a very difficult question to
answer if you know your task and all 19
a couple of cases where we have seen
tremendous valuable contribution from
these deep networks and also what we see
in images that's also quite important
for us as I said if you conduct on we
have a lot of images when you make a
certain website you go to a hotel page
and then you start scrolling through the
gallery to see if the hotel room you
liked or not so that gives us a lot of
actually playground to see a benefiting
images so what we actually see in them
does it make sense for us to use it okay
[Music]
then how do we use image content so
let's say we know what is existing in
image how can we use it to help
customers that's also another important
area I'm in Tokyo and our following that
the second part will be about the
recommendations I can use these networks
for recommending hotels or
kind of autistic regression or your
linear regression problem committed this
using some embeddings very similar to
the previous book very nice actually
and finally stars will cover about how
we are scaling this right here is huge
demand from our users we have millions
of users every day and how can we scale
this without breaking that's that is
challenge so let's start quickly deep
learning is isolating very very powerful
for many of the tasks and we see and
hear a lot in our job interviews for any
small kind of problem people try to use
deep learning it might work but maybe
there are easier ways to do it and it
also could be faster so that's why I'm
gonna just mention very famous use cases
that we have seen again tremendous
improvement starting with image knife at
2012 it are electrically shaky we have
seen a very nice implementation of a
convolutional net work on p.m. India
GPUs for the first time I guess so it is
shown that it can it can move the needle
at image net competition I think from a
race of top five and thirty percent it
decreased to like 18 or something I'm
not you
so following that of course not on use
the other older descriptors or in like
saved fog Gaussian mixture models they
were kind of forgotten very quickly
that's okay we have to move on and also
very nice sometimes fun like the
applications we've seen like image
styling style transfer actually so for
any image you can transfer it to any
specific style of a painter like Hong
Kong so that's also application course
recently generate registered networks
they've been very very interesting and I
think there is a little bit more time we
have to understand what they are
actually doing and how we can use them
and also for text in machine translation
I've seen very nice results google has
recently changed their translator tool
to new networks and also on speech with
a deep mind awareness by
people's and recently to cut off from
Google are also showing very very
humanely performances and finally deep
and wide which is a title of the paper
and Austin Texas 2016 so Google is also
using such at least they are saying that
they're using it on the Play Store and
YouTube's recommendation which gives us
a quite nice intuition that it should
make definitely worth a try so moving on
the images in the first part okay so
what we see in images actually this is a
very easy and of a very difficult
question so when I have a look at this
image I can see that there's a chair
there is a TV bed balcony a lamp on the
ceiling but so for booking.com but it
makes a difference or not is another
question I when I take this image and
put it through a commercial API I get
the following results most optimal X
will be quite correct so it's oceanfront
nature the child's building tan tiles
apartment with the confidence levels you
can see which as I said mostly correct
but does it really make sense for us to
use it on our website that's why we had
to come up with a solution of our own
because we have a very unique Otis here
mostly Hotel images right we don't see
zebra hopefully or maybe if it makes to
zoo a hotel to be mindful to see zebra
but mostly we won't see them that's why
we have to adapt these networks to for
our focus that's what we did actually
and now if you look at this photo you
would like to see that it's the photo of
a room so as we good start and its
interior that's also nice and it's
looking over the sea so we can tell okay
if you're looking for a CV in your hotel
that one could be a nice choice for you
and there is a bed that's nice that you
can sleep on that's the reason that we
cannot just take away any existing
solution we need to build our own fair
enough and we can do it because it's
quite straightforward these days
but again our unique corpus makes us a
little bit different we can adjust to
the image net classifiers because
differentiating between cats and dogs
will not help us and you have to come up
with our own labels right that's also
quite a huge challenge because what's a
good label why should we try to
recognize a bad or but not achievement
bar in balcony or like TV should we also
try to understand the coffee cups so
easy so this this problem internally
brought a lot of challenges or that's
one just gonna name couple of them and
also multi classes right or most our
images are multiple ladies so it's a
sort of a room also it is about it as a
wheel so we had to be very good in terms
of defining our loss function to handle
multiple process and also can use the
hierarchy in these images so if you know
that it's a bad then it should be an
interior right I mean unless you are
really going for a crazy hotel the
inaccuracy
yeah the grating accuracy of a
classifier also requires a lot of human
attention and finally we have to scale
it because we are receiving more than
200 thousand images per day these are
mostly coming from the new partners
joining or from our users from our
visitors just like you stay in a hotel
in absurdum tonight
you like it or you don't like it
whatever the reason is you upload the
image and write a review I like it
because it has a nice feel because it
was not very clean
so you upload it and then it helps the
next customer rank they would like to
stay in that hotel and also this gives
us a nice way to give a seed like to do
period that's where I can make input so
again now we know let's say help is done
in the images and how can we use it
how can use it for personalization
that's what we are going for we like to
personalize your experience when you log
into your line you come to our website
so if you're looking for a beach resort
we know that you'll then probably want
to see if the value is nice and maybe it
makes sense to show you more of the
beach images or the same input so if you
can identify all of these automatically
we can show them
in a better you'll find hopefully and
then you can enjoy that Elana make your
decision again if you're looking for a
breakfast included hotel it also makes
sense to identify the breakfast photos
and actually to our users and how do we
decide if showing anything is good or
not of course we don't make such
decisions at booking.com we let our
users go through the website and get the
signal and the feedback from our users
if they enjoy they will show this signal
to us and then we make extensive ad
tests on our website to make the proper
decision
most of the noisy application if you
know all the if we can identify all the
food photos coming from our users we can
also get the lat/long from the images in
the eggs if they are not corrupted now
we can pinpoint them on a very nice menu
on a map so this is just a very minor
very small scale example I think around
maybe 10,000 images you can see here and
we just plot them on the map you can
click on them this is again for fun
purposes for visualization and you can
see where people eat and what they eat
and if we know this we can tell okay if
you're staying in a hotel now if you
want to eat maybe there is a nice rest
on you and there are some photos from
our users so knowing this whole
information gives open the new era for
us let's say and we can personalize your
state so that's mostly about images as
you might imagine we also have a huge
challenge in terms of recommending
hotels or anything on our website and
that's why we spend some time to
understand if there's value of using
neural networks and now I'm not doing
actually and then I think if you because
when you make the presentation last
night so this is again about how to
train a deep network basically just I'd
like to mention so you can come up with
two website you can get a lot of image
data you can collect your labels and
then train a network from scratch that's
a very
the wrong way to do another ballon way
to do it is actually take a pre train
network and use the embeddings let's say
from the final nails and I'm trying to
change them with the new labels so this
is called this is nothing but the
transfer learning where you basically
have a each variety of labels and data
here and then you create your model when
using this model you transfer the
embeddings all the way to a new model
and now with a fever of course data you
can now again train your network so this
is a very useful way where you have a
wide variety of information on your base
model and you have limited corpus or
limited number of examples on your final
the final test file let's revisit the
last slide of the images no not yet
so evolution of defect pictures right
so you've seen in literature ok I get my
signal I should be little bit faster so
in the in the history starting from 1997
the a theory the first network on the
left is like you learn it from chemical
it's been used very widely for OCR and
it was shown very nicely dot but the
corpus was small and combinations are
implemented on on a CV of course but
then it has changed a lot so with the
second network here from Alex Cruz yes
Keith one-eyed National for the image
net competition that move the needle has
led up to this whole new networks so
this is only very part of success so
this is Lynette elects net
vgg Google net inception in 73 and this
is resonates only 52 so there is another
version of 1000 lines which will make
all of them vanish nothing in scale so
what we did is actually we took multiple
of these modern art architectures and it
later on we trained a lot and then so
the what we pick the one that was giving
a nice trade of beating computation time
and accuracy yes darling witches are
over I'm moving very
to the next part where I'm going to talk
about how to use the network about for
recommending a hotel or any other action
for your users so we have users coming
out coming to our website and booking a
hotel like this is why we get the signal
and none of you like to use this data
information to recommend the hotel for
the next user and how we do it is
basically we can define our problem with
a supervised learning problem where our
objective is to find the probability of
booking a hotel so we'd like to if we
can find it nicely then we can recommend
hotels to the users in a descending
order and what kind of features we can
use actually we have a lot of features
of course from our users from the hotels
and we select whatever we like like we
define our user features could be a
country language of the user and then we
can also get contextual features like
the day of week to account for
seasonality and on the item features of
course the price of the hotel will make
a huge difference in your decision also
made the location and again our final
goals find a probability of booking
given these user contextual and the item
features what you can do is basically
training logistic regression which has
been a powerful tool in industry for
many different tasks if you know how to
use it it could be very very powerful
again and it's very widely available on
most of the libraries and frameworks and
what this paper from Google the one
below the presenter is that if we can
take this logistic regression and emerge
it with a deep network we can account
for the manual ization coming from
logistic regression and the
generalization coming from the deep
network so that's what the paper is
claiming and actually what this does is
this white part they call it which is
logistic regression has input features
but with the city Wi-Fi is free Wi-Fi or
not then you also use the cross feature
cell like interactions if the users from
Amsterdam
prefer
free Wi-Fi hotels and if they do it
frequently now maybe it's something we
should to know maybe it should be when
you're old now maybe for all users from
Epsilon we should always show the free
Wi-Fi hotels this is of course as an
example you can come up with a similar
example for your domain and the close
feature is actually very very important
because we would like to assign a very
strong bias actually for these frequent
occurrences of the item and user players
and what we like to do on the deep part
is actually take these features again
but this time not use them directly but
ever embedding layer in between which is
initialized randomly and learnt
throughout the training on the back
provocation we will learn these
embeddings so this is not something we
define this is something the network
decides depending on the output so this
is again a supervised learning problem
embeddings are fed into the fully the
fully connected layers with linear
activations and ended and there is a
sigmoid activation is so the idea of
this deep part is that it will be able
to generalize with the help of these
embeddings for also unseen items like an
inn hotel joining without the
information of the user behavior on this
hotel we can generalize very easily so
it can also account for the cold start
problem and learning these damp dance
embeddings could also help a lot for
other tasks and how to combine we have
the white part which is segregation we
have the deep-dish part as I call two
hidden layers of fully connected with
advanced embedding now you like to
combine them together and you just
combine them concatenate the feature
vectors here and then add a sigmoid
layer or a linearly depending on your
task this paper is focusing on the
probability of user
installing an S that's right the sigmoid
layer there and now you can just back
propagate so the idea of this network is
that it would learn memorize very
frequent items on the right part and try
to generalize for the unseen exam
in the training set on the deep part we
are the embeddings so that's the
motivation but this is nothing different
than the bias-variance tradeoff that we
all know so the bias is the algorithms
tendency to consistently learn the wrong
thing this switch is also called
underfitting
and the variance is the algorithms
tendency to learn random things like
outliers and this is also called
overfitting like in this example this is
the example of a price house price
versus the size of a house as you can
see as the size grows higher the price
increases but it will also saturate a
dump its own plane one and if you try to
model this with a first-order polynomial
like a line it will probably give a nice
distribution but it will probably also
give a high bias right you'll be good at
generalizing so you won't be backward
also on the contrary if you try to model
this spot the distribution with a fourth
order polynomial
it feels very nicely over sit and give a
very small error on the tested and this
is the case of the high variance but if
you can model it at the correct level in
terms of the context purity model we can
very nicely fit a polynomial it will be
good at test and train again where it is
why they're in some bias scheme comes
from is actually you have a model that
gives an output here for given any X we
would like to get the output Y and E is
the sensor noise here which is an all
this normal distribution with Sigma and
if you define the scheduler error
function here we can rewrite as X
expected value of the actual value minus
the predicted value and square if you
rewrite it which is quite straight
phones actually we can rewrite this one
in this formula right and this is
actually nothing but the square of the
bias plus the variance and irreducible
error here so the best predictor in this
case would try to minimize both parents
and the bias but it will come the point
that you will not be able to minimize so
again for illustrative purposes for our
understanding usually usually
if you go in a high complex model just
like the one in our previous example in
the hearts priority if you go fourth
order polynomial you'll be better at
decreasing your bias so you over it so
you'll get very nice results in your
training set but then total error will
not be very nice so there is usually a
kind of a nice point in between in model
complexity on the x-axis and how we do
this balancing between writing an
account no slack
so how could we have this balance
between the bottom vice and the
trade-off is with this network this is
what it's claimed by jointly jointly
optimizing for both wide and deep part
and also this formula here takes into
account both the Wi-Fi the logistic
regression fear the interaction where X
is the input with a deep part so this is
the major difference actually a very
nice approach compared to the ensemble
methods like random forests where we
train multiple trees independently and
then we assume they are all weak
learners and then we try to get like a
consensus out of these trees and there
are very very strong class files but
this is I think it's a very nice idea it
tries to jointly optimize these both
parts accounting for the variance and
the price and finally of course we need
a code pie data it's quite actually
straightforward to use these existing
models this is a code snippet of course
it will take a little bit more lines but
you can define your define your sparse
codons very easily and then define your
continuous real problem and then this is
how we define across Coulomb interaction
and then again embedding colors which
you will embed and each for which you
will learn the weights throughout back
propagation and on you try to fit your
DN and model which in this case hidden
ins of thousand five hundred and two
thousand two hundred and you just press
on fit and it probably takes some time
depending on your data set and now we
have to scale this and that's where
stuff is going to talk about everyone I
want to guide you through process how we
train and deploy models in working
Diplo's in Oaxaca so what if we use
standard flow for deep models it's good
to start with on your laptop you created
your prototype you did some first test
and it's nice but what if you want to
speed up your training what if you want
to run it on not on your laptop but but
on a server or bunch of them meaning
cluster and what if you have many
colleagues who want to do exactly the
same so the resources of cluster need to
be somehow managed and the thing that
works the best for us for so far is
kubernetes kubernetes is open source
artificial platform for continuous
application applications so basically
what we do we tell kubernetes please
create a pod which is set of containers
for us and we can define resources which
we require for our job it can be number
of CPUs it can be amount of memory one
and starting from kubernetes 1.3 or it
also supports scheduling workloads
unrevealed which gives us a lot of
flexibility about what hardware work
hardware and software we can use ok
also when we run training suite we
export logs to a shared storage such as
HDFS or NFS to visualize the training
process later cause for some
the textures it can take a while to
train model for instance OOP one second
[Music]
for instance we run a high-tech primary
search on for using say experience but
you can tell about experiment a it's a
loss function for both training
emulation validation set basically it's
not converging so probably we should
give up on this type frame hi-hi third
parameter configuration
what about B sorry okay oh yes it's a
fail the better than a but it stops a
lot stop decreasing so probably we're
not going to continue with it
what about C the promising way we have
both actually training loss and
validation was so the time the very
similar yeah probably with trains we can
say in for more because loss training
loss and validation also still degrading
so this tiny Keens you can get from
visualization training process are super
fine so also often we want to retrain
model daily weekly or by schedule it
seems to be straight for resting but
there is another step appears so after
we train models on our laptop or
controlled environment we can evaluate
the model behavior but if we train
models automatically what we can tell
about model properties of the model how
does the model behaves behave as
expected so we probably want to collect
some metrics and validate them against
health checks so we can measure the loss
ABC or any electricity
of model we want then validate them
against predefined values so it will
help us to understand if model not going
crazy we also put metadata file with the
this model matrix together will model
just to make sure in the future we can
easily understand what what we are there
is also a model and if everything is
fine we deployed model if not we notify
owners to take a look then to deploy
model we use containerized storing
basically we built a very generic
application that can serve mostly every
thunderstorm model it exposes HTTP HTTP
API to query prediction we want any
right this the stateless application we
developed which allows us to easily
scale serving part as we go also we rely
on kubernetes to make the serving
resilient so we know that we have enough
computing power to serve predictions
another challenge for deploying model is
good but at the end we want to query
predictions so what we want we want we
want to know total time that it takes to
get all the predictions we want so this
is a simple formula with by request
overhead here I mean time it takes to
encode features to send them to decode
the predictions if we use any any
protocol deck and for simpler more
simple models like logistic regression
or given life request overhead can be
much higher than actual computation time
so if you want to use these predictions
in production environment let's say on
page view we won
to optimize relationship the first thing
I would do if I want to optimize for
latency try not to predict online and
put these put these computations of
light to create a lookup table and fetch
predictions from a look up look up title
if it's possible then if it's not and we
want really if we need to if you can't
recompute and we want to get predictions
in a very low latency manner we can
actually embed the model to the address
space of the application so there would
be close to nothing request our hats
time and also if our computation time
for our model is huge we can just
predict for one instance at a time
so we can have multiple reserving that
peak just for one Winston's but this can
also be tricky because if you want to
paralyze listing the total prediction
time would be not less than the slowest
predictor also tender flow has some nice
tricks such as quantization when you
reduce precision of your parameters to
from flow 3252 fixed point integer a
which gives you for time even more
actually for time more computing power
and it can see the model pensions for
time less memory also there are a few
other tricks such as removing unneeded
nodes from the graph and so-called
functionalities function so-called
optimized for insurance which remove
unneeded nodes and converts variables to
constants which also gives a little bit
of an improvement then if we want to
predict for large number of instances
and we are not if you want to believe on
large number instances we can watch
requests together so at a time we
predict
on an examples which can increase
latency it's fine but it's always a
trade-off between latency you want to
have an amount of predictions you can
get also for throughput it's very
natural to optimize to send requests in
parallel and this is how our amazing
platform looks like we rely on
kubernetes as a alkylation framework to
serve to run containers there with
simple HTTP service that sends
predictions back this is these leaves
behind load balancer and for offline
clients we want to sometimes put data
right to Hadoop and sometimes to my
sequel but for online clients we want to
have a prediction say for if you want to
use the model on purpose view you want
to get it very very quickly so basically
the serving pipe exactly the same for
both offline in online clients and
clients has a power has the power to
choose which strategy to follow optimize
for latency or optimized for throughput
this setup works fine so far thank you
[Applause]